previously on the heavy spoilers show
and if you want me to see Alien 3 make
sure you comment below thank you peace
hopefully not don't you dare comment me
I'm not watching alien 3.
here we go again so after dropping two
big breakdowns on alien and Aliens it
was of course inevitable that it
eventually had to touch on alien 3.
hated by its director burned by the fans
upon its release and constantly
surrounded by controversy I think this
is a film that's definitely worth
discussing now if you ask people whether
they love the first two movies then
chances are you're gonna get the exact
same answer in the case of Alien 3
though it normally depends on who you
talk to and the films build a fan base
even though it was extremely divisive at
the time now before getting into the
actual breakdown of the film I think we
have to talk about what it went through
to get us to this point in total there's
rumored to be over 30 different scripts
for the film and it got to a point that
fox was so frustrated with everything
that they just put their foot down and
dropped a teaser announcing that there
would be a new alien movie releasing in
1992 spending six years in development
Fox wanted to make a sequel that was
more aliens than alien and early on
there was a lot of back and forth with
Brandywine Productions those guys didn't
want to just do a repeat of the first
two films whereas Fox wanted a military
style movie sent it around Hicks
fighting his Xenomorphs on either Earth
or their home planet we discovered in
space
no one can hear you scream
in 1992
discover on Earth
everyone can hear you scream
a speculation was rightly fueled by that
tagline and if their time had have been
around then then everyone would have
correctly guessed that something was
happening on Earth however the movie
went through eight drafts after that and
things changed to immensely now the
reason that they had to settle on Hicks
was that things had become difficult
with Sigourney Weaver after the release
of aliens if you checked out our
breakdown on that movie then you'll know
she was Furious that the daughter plot
got cut from the film and though it was
eventually added in the director's cut
it burned a lot of bridges it has to die
however the studio didn't really see
that as being too much of a bad thing
after all Ripley had got a happy ending
taking udice surrogatora and faced up to
her fears in the alien Nest she was
gonna count me on Alien 3 which we'll
talk about later on but it's important
to bear in mind she wasn't a major part
of this movie so Hicks was seen as the
way to go and Brandywine wanted to look
into the Weyland yutani Corporation as
being the big bad they operated in the
background of the first two films and
though the Zen wolves were the threat it
was definitely them putting the people
in the situation described as being like
a cold war Hicks would deal with the
weapons division of the corporation who
were Mass producing the Xenomorphs to
use as biological weapons and that takes
us to the William Gibson script which
was the first solid draft that fox had
we joined the solar Cove floating in
space which is where it would be found
by some socialists known as the union of
progressive peoples boarding The Vessel
they'd be attacked by a face again that
had hid in the entrails of Bishop's body
though they killed it they realized
there was more here than just a Savage
Mission and they took the solarco to a
space station shopping mall hybrid known
as The Anchor Point Ripley was in a coma
and Hicks would then explore the vessel
only to find Waylon yutani developing an
alien Army the film would then end with
it setting up a fourth movie and this
would take things to the alien Homeworld
which would close out the franchise
after Nightmare on Elm Street 4 Randy
Holland was attached to direct and along
with his Animorphs he really wanted to
explore the origins of this space jockey
although this version never got made you
can find out what happened in it as
there's an audiobook version available
along with a comic that kind of flashes
things out now before we get into the
rest of the breakdown I just want to
give a huge shout out to
comicbookdirect.com it's a perfect place
for collectors and the way that it works
is that you can either purchase a book
individually or you can subscribe to the
entire run to make sure you never miss
it they work with all the big Publishers
including Marvel in DC and also have
lots of different alien comics on there
too I'm just getting back into reading
them I'm really enjoying it and yeah I
definitely recommend you go and check
them out if this video has piqued your
interest now if you use the link in the
description below you're also going to
get 20 off so definitely head over there
right after this anyway back into the
video where we'll get into the movie
next and after just wrapping up the
William Gibson plan and also all the
different versions the screenplay had a
big following on the internet and when
you read it you can see that you know
this might have been better however the
producers were dragging their feet and
asking for constant rewrites so things
fell up part and Rennie Holland went off
to go and do die hard 2. and that takes
us into the Eric Red version which
centered around Special Forces boarding
the solarco to find everyone dead from
here things moved to a small U.S city
and we kind of got the plot of this in
Aliens vs Predator 2. given less than
two months to do his draft red is
completely disowned his script due to
how rushed it was and the brandy wines
ended up rejecting it because of how far
it's straight from their Vision in comes
the next version written by David Dwight
who is putting it together in a vastly
different world due to the Cold War now
being over the metaphors with Hicks were
outdated and thus he decided to change
things up and set the film on a prison
planet they saw well in yutani carrying
out human experiments with the
facehuggers and interestingly this later
got picked up in Alien Resurrection now
it was at this time that the problems
with the absence Sigourney Weavers
started to arise box President Joe Roth
thought that Ripley was the centerpiece
of the series and he championed her as
being one of the only female action
stars that we had in Hollywood Sigourney
was offered four million dollars and
also given a producer's credit which is
when things started to take shape now
again kinda need to talk about our last
breakdown to explain what's going on
here but if you watch that then you'll
know we brought up sigourney's demands
for that film when being approached by
aliens she said she wanted no guns in
the film that she would die at the end
of the movie and that she would also
have sex with the alien as we know this
never happened but now without producing
credit she got to do two out of three
Dwight worked her into his script but he
stepped away from the project when he
learned Fox were working behind his back
with another writer that's when the ball
got rolling with the Navigator's Vincent
Ward who was invited to direct the
people in charge of aliens had seen his
movie and they loved the tone of it
thinking that it would be perfect for
what they were wanting to go for now in
case you haven't seen it it's initially
set during the black death and we watch
his medieval villagers dig a hole in the
ground that takes them to the 20th
century it's mixing medieval with the
modern which you kind kind of feel when
you watch the finished version of alien
3. Ward didn't really like this script
though and instead he wanted Ripley to
crash on a monastery like satellite made
mostly of wood yes that's right mostly
of wood the monks on this would have
rejected all technology and they saw
Ripley crashing down as being like a
fallen star are there strange things
started happening with the xenomorph and
it was believed that she'd brought the
devil with her which led to her being
put on trial she's also pregnant with
the alien queen in that version and
eventually decides to sacrifice herself
in order to finally kill it box wanted
an alternate ending shot in which she
led but Sigourney Weaver said she'd only
do the film if she died at the end
although most of this was scrapped there
were elements brought across such as the
almost all male cast the vow of celibacy
the pregnancy and Ripley's death Ward's
version was seen to be more like an art
film rather than something they could
Market though and they but they brought
up how stupid it was having a wooden
planet in space they wanted to turn the
monks and into prisoners and the planet
into an oil refinery and what event she
was fired after you refused to do this
thus that leads into what we get and
though really Scott was asked to direct
but reasons are known he ended up
turning it down now David Fincher was
picked last minute and though he's gone
on to have a big career he wasn't really
known for much at the time primarily
he'd worked as a music video director
and had done work for Aerosmith Rolling
Stones Billy Idol and Paula Abdul to the
studio they were getting the guy who
made Madonna's Vogue but we know from
his sensibilities now that the guy
doesn't do big popcorn movies I love
Finch's work but it has to be said that
his movies have a bleakness to them
though the game has a happy ending to it
most of his films don't and his next
movie after this would be seven which
yeah we know how that ended I saw you
with the Box what was in the Box because
I envy your normal life Put the gun down
babe it seems that Envy is myself no
what's in the box
finches often talked about how Ridley
Scott's alien is one of his favorite
films and you can definitely see that
influence the vision we get here however
he too fell victim to Fox's meddling and
eventually stepped away from the movie
when it was in post-production shot for
a year and edited for the air Fox
demanded reshoots to fix things and he
walked away from it after handing over
an assembly cut though the special
edition release of the movie says that
it's a director's cut it's important to
bear in mind that Fincher never gave his
approval and he did never go back to the
movie to fix things up the way I tend to
Remember the movie is through the
assembly curve I repressed that
theatrical won and after going back to
it for this review I was shocked at how
incoherent it is things fly by A
Breakneck Speed without explanation and
the extra 30 minutes in the assembly cut
really fleshes things out the changes
come early on and we get an extended
burst stack with more establishing shots
Ripley washing up on the beach and the
lights that shows why the colony has to
shave their heads it's only slightly
referenced in the theatrical and along
with the beat shots you really get the
idea that Ripley's landed in hell now
the most major change comes in the form
of what creature that the xenomorph
bursts out of in the theatrical cut the
Facehugger attaches onto a dog whereas
the assembly cut has it going on to an
ox the ox was thought to be too
cumbersome and you could probably just
tip over the cow xenomorph and then run
away was supposed to be old Haggard and
basically a metaphor for Ripley that
showed how the prisoners treated women
the studio thought that that idea was
stupid though and that for the alien to
be scary it needed to come from
something scary now the Rottweiler was
deemed far more ferocious and agile and
thus this is what was used in the
theatrical cut now Paul mcgann's Golic
is almost absent from the theatrical
curve but the psychopath gets way more
air time in the extended version in both
balms who watches Ripley in the
prisoners launcher plan to trap the
xenomorph in a room used to house toxic
waste depending on what version you get
gives us a different outcome with it
failing in the theatrical whilst it
works in the assembly and this cut has
garlic seen as xenomorph as a dragon and
he eventually frees the Beast and
unleashes it on the prisoners to him
he's had a religious experience in a
tunnel and the last person that the
xenomorph grabs even has a crucifix on
their head it ties back into the whole
Monk and Satan thing that we talked
about before and basically gives his
character a reason for being in the film
instead of how Fox handle him eventually
now lastly we have Ripley's death scene
which has a chess burster coming out of
her in the theatrical this was actually
done through reshoots with them even
giving Sigourney a bald cap so she
didn't have to shave her head again in
the assembly cut the chest burster is
cut out but yeah fire effect it all
still is kinda goofy I actually prefer
the chest burster yeah don't shoot me
this was actually done to show Ripley
nurturing it almost like a mother
nurtures a newborn it's your other
connection between her and the species
in the studio Manda area because the
original ending was too close to
Terminator 2. it's very much a picky
poison with this moment but rather than
some extra character beats those are the
main difference is that you get from
both versions
[Music]
foreign
or rather a good one as they integrate
the alien's score into the 20th Century
Fox Fanfare like the prior two films we
open on space but whereas Ripley was
peacefully sleeping during this we get
some slight differences there are some
inconsistencies here and we do see a
shot of Ripley a nude asleep in their
pods not to be like actually but they
couldn't actually get their hands on the
ones from the end of aliens which had a
slightly different shape to them thus
they had to use the hibernation pods
from the first film which I'm guessing
you didn't notice but the movies just
set out to ruin everything about that
prior film so I don't care if I ruin it
as well and as the names come in we get
cuts of what's happening on the solaco
this originally was a massive point of
contention for the fan base as the film
never actually explains what it is
happening here however we can look at
the novel to finally get some answers
written by Alan Dean Foster he too
clashed with the studio a bit and he had
to Cobble together several different
scripts in order to make the companion
he also wanted to keep news live and he
was planning on saying her cryachi was
damaged meaning that she had to remain
asleep in it for the events of the movie
this was shut down though and in the end
he didn't get everything he needed and
thus the bug deficit in some ways for
example Elizabeth where Ripley scratches
her heading contract slice and she also
says that she didn't have a daughter due
that plot being cut from the original
aliens Ripley also goes up in the vents
when looking for the xenomorph whereas
in the film she goes into the basement
Dylan also escapes a larva in the book
and he almost acts on his promise to
kill Ripley but just before he can do it
the xenomorph burst out and kills him
anyway back at the beginning and though
warning is shown in the film The Book
explains that there was at least two of
them I think for the film to work you
have to take it as they're being three
but either way here's what happens in
this scene so a Facehugger crawls out of
its egg and it goes to get nude which is
when we see the glass in the front of
her pod crack this cuts the face hugger
which then bleeds on the floor and this
is where the electrical fire is started
from that brings the ship down now they
are trying to misdirect us and make us
believe that newt's the one who got the
Facehugger on her so that they can do
the twist later on with Ripley being the
carrier we see an x-ray of her face
hooker on someone at some point whereas
with Ripley they never go and show it
however there is a clue and the glass on
her pod has a cracked hole in it showing
how the Facehugger entered it for the
final one HR Giga was brought back to
work on the project and there is concept
of an aquatic base hooker which would
have survived the crash and then swam to
the shore another bit of trivia for you
is that there was supposed to be a
prosthetic ribly used for this opener
with the bass hooker however according
to our culture the VFX team
unfortunately didn't have enough time to
do one of Sigourney Weaver instead they
quickly grabbed the Merrell's strip head
from the comedy that becomes her but a
curly black wig on it so you can't tell
the difference now in the Escape pod
they dropped down to the Double Y
chromosome prism Planet which we see is
known as fiorina though the nickname
says Fury the word actually pulls from
Latin and it means flower bloom or
lastly in a since I tend to gravitate
more towards the last one being why it's
been adopted here as these prisoners are
very much trying to return to a state of
that they don't want sinner Temptation
in this world but Ripley coming down of
course ends up changing this also I know
I keep calling them prisoners um but in
the assembly cut they say that well and
yutani wanted to shut down the facility
but they wanted to stay as custodians
are like some are locked up but also
some of their voluntarily so they're not
really prisoners but then somehow look
it's messy either way Double Y seems to
be a weird way to list things and if you
watched our other videos you know we
talked about how Lambert was listed as
being a male at Birth in Aliens and how
they talked about arturian poontang
being so good it doesn't matter if
they're a guy or a girl don't want to go
down a big rabbit hole on it as it might
be a reach but this could be further
building off the back of the creative
team saying genders are more fluid in
the future therefore everyone's designed
by the chromosomes they have which is
why this is listed as Double Y instead
of being a mixture anyway in the film we
do still get those religious metaphors
and Sigourney saw Ripley having a shaven
head as being similar to Joan of Arc
Joan was burned at the stake for heresy
and Ripley's Journey here to culminate
in her death being brought on by fire
when she asks Dylan to end her life she
also puts her arms out in a christ-like
pose which he mirrors at the end when
falling into the rat and we could see
his sacrifices saving the rest of the
prisoners as well which is a christ-like
sort of thing to do even though at this
point there's like one person left now
the xenomorph could also be seen as a
demonic presence with Golic worshiping
it and Satan is also described as being
like a dragon in the Bible the ship was
supposed to be based on the Star of
Bethlehem the monks are of course
changed to prisoners and there are those
that think the oxforders are metaphors
for Shepherds upon taking the animals in
they say Christmas has come early and
prayers recited throughout the entire
prison at the end of the film we also
see some of the prisoners get red rings
on the top of their heads and these
could be seen as Halos further evoking
this idea now this scene actually takes
place at blast which I've visited a
number of times and though you instantly
get the bleakness from this opening I
promise it doesn't look that [__] in
real life some celebrities even visit it
like Sigourney Weaver and of course
world famous YouTube mega star sensation
Kevin spoilers now we have the natural
beauty of the sand mixed in with the
industrial cranes and it gives the
planet a feeling like blast Beach is
about to get zero stars on TripAdvisor
now you might not notice this but the
creative team actually used parts of an
X-Wing in order to create this miniature
crane twin Suns also appear in this shot
possibly linking back to Luke's Home on
Tatooine now at this point we meet
Clemens who very much becomes a sort of
Dallas archetype Earth carried as a prop
dip as seemingly major protagonist but
they're killed at the movie's midpoint
to show No One Is Safe he shows the
complexity of these prisoners as well
and he also represents a rehabilitation
that they can all go through previously
a doctor we learned he became addicted
to Morphine when he was back in medical
school one day there was a giant
industrial accident which caused the
death of several workers and along with
this brought a number of casualties
called in to help he was so high he
prescribed the wrong dosage of
painkillers and in turn this caused the
death of 11 people jailed for seven
years on the planet he ended up staying
there when his sentence ended because he
realized that he had nowhere else to go
his medical license had been reduced to
a class 3C which Echoes how Ripley's
license was downgraded in Aliens after
the hearing now Ripley recognizes he's a
prisoner because he has a bar cut on the
back of his head which we see the
inmates sporting early on in the film
it's likely inspired Agent 47 in the
Hitman series and to me it being
tattooed on shows the corporation now
owns these people forever though they
may leave the prison they'll never
actually be able to escape its confines
which adds to why Clemens probably
decided to remain behind he also
represents how loose's structures of
authorities are within the prison when
the warden is shown to us he's
surrounded by prisoners but he's on the
lower deck whilst a lot of the them
stand above him this is to show that he
isn't the one looking down on them and
we get the idea that there's this
imbalance within the prison we learn in
the assembly cut that the prisoners
could overthrow him at any time and they
even have it on a system in place when
it comes to things like the axes and so
on however if they killed him already
far then the supplies would stop coming
in and they'd be stuck on this planet
without the corporation's help although
Charles Dance kills it as Clemens the
role was originally offered to Richard E
Grant Venture wanted to reunite him
alongside with nail and I co-stars Ralph
Brown and Paul McGann but alas it wasn't
meant to be now Ripley is brought in and
I don't know if I'm reaching here but
when Sigourney gets dropped on the table
I don't know if she's pushing out her
stomach to try and imply pregnancy but
it does seem like she has got a bump
look she's got a great figure mate I'm
not hating you but just the way she's
framed on the bed it was at least going
through my mind don't don't cancel me
now as the prisoner search the wreck
dreams are destroyed and they come
across what's left of the crew members
this includes bishop and also Hicks who
at this points completely unrecognizable
Michael Bina it was it was so stuff that
he'd been killed off like this and he
wouldn't even allow them to make a dummy
of him hence why it's so mangled in the
end being reluctantly agreed they could
use a photo of him and the actors joke
that he actually got paid more to not be
in the movie than he did for working for
10 months on Aliens now inside the
prison we meet Charles S Dutton who's
playing Dylan in the novel he has a
single dreadlock but they don't go with
this in the live action because of the
colony's lice problem in early drafts of
the script Dylan was known as Malcolm
and it's possible at the Malcolm X
classes he wears or a carryover from
this Dunham was actually jailed early on
in his life but manslaughter and when he
was doing his time he got into acting
and built a career upon his release he
said he channeled this for his character
in the film and I definitely think he
brings a lot with him for this really
memorable role now Clemens tends to
Ripley and the reason she's so knocked
out this point is not only because of
the crash but also because of the cry
bio tube these were built to awaken
their subjects slowly but being thrown
out of one means that half your body's
asleep whilst the other part of it's
awake leads to this sort of Hangover
feeling but Ripley also does something
subtle upon coming too she starts to rub
her neck which is probably sore from the
Facehugger being down there to implant
the embryo throughout the movie this
gets worse and worse and it calls back
to when shuoka from The Nightmare on
Aliens and grabbed her chest at this
point Clemens tells her the bad news
about Hicks and Newt obviously this
annoyed all the fans at the time as it
killed off their favorites and made the
events of the last movie completely
pointless repeat at the start of this
movie is almost exactly where she was at
the end of the first film and James
Cameron also said that it ruined his
happy ending but you approve killing
John colomate which did the same [__] so
[__] you anyway
sorry if you're watching this James I
didn't mean I'm just joking there now
Ripley demands to see the bodies after
suspecting Newt might have been infected
the Shadow the start had her mouth wide
open in the cryo tube and this is was
meant to make us think that it hadn't
got her because we could clearly see her
face again though it flies by so quickly
that you can't really pick it up but
yeah that's why it was used the way it
was we also don't get a return of the
actress behind you either as I'm shaking
guess she had kind of aged out of the
role Carrie Hen at this point was
replaced by Daniel Edmonds who took over
nude and like Carrie this is the only
film she ever starred in a ruby starts
to inspect air and she says she's
searching for cholera Clemens says that
there hasn't been an affection over in
over 200 years and we know from the
timeline that this movie takes place in
2179 the original took place in 2122 57
years ago making this film take place in
the same year that the prior aliens did
that's why the bishop at the end can
look like an Android even though he's
supposed to be a human look we'll get
into that mess later on in the video
anyway Clemens uses Colora as an excuse
to the warden as to why he had to carry
out the autopsy and due to him in 85
being thick they just don't question it
now from here we go to the arc scene
which wasn't fully film for the movie so
they had to Cobble it together with
parts of the stuff we shot without
Fincher in order to release it here we
get the alien birth shot alongside the
funeral of Newton Hicks and we're very
much meant to have this juxtaposition of
death and birth together the bodies are
also wrapped up and they appear similar
to how Kane's body did in that first
film Ripley also gets a nosebleed at
this point which is something that she's
had throughout all of the films anyway
here we see the smaller alien coming out
which was nicknamed the Bambi burster by
those in the prop shop though it looks
like early CGI there was actually very
little use in this film with it only
being applied for the Flying Day pre on
the planet and the xenomorph's head
cracking with the sprinkler the rest was
achieved through the use of a rod puppet
which was then superimposed on top of
the film now for some of the close-ups
they also went back to using a man in a
suit they also had plans of using an
actual dog no behind the scenes images
of a dog with a xenomorph costume on
that they were gonna have running around
who was gonna be ridiculous and hark ego
was also brought on to reconceptualize
the creature and Design line what he
imagined it to look like if it had come
from a four-legged animal they also
nearly went back to his original designs
and at one point did a Model that had
human lips a Ripley gets a head shaved
and then showers and she wraps her arms
around herself as she does it why am I
bringing this up well I'm not perfect
and it's because Alien Resurrection
actually uses this imagery when we see
the Ripley clone bald with her arms
wrapped around her just like this shot I
think I got away with it now on top of
the Joan of Arc metaphors now playing
also pointed out that in some way she's
meant to resemble a cancer patient she
adds something metastizing inside of her
that will kill her and the shaven head
Echoes what happens to people going
through chemotherapy now it's not too
long before the xenomorph grows and
snake skin like shedding is found in one
of the fans nice little touch is that
you can see lice moving around showing
how much they infect every aspect of the
planet xenomorph spits acid in the
inmate's face who you might recognize as
being Christopher Fairbank he starred in
a number of things such as Batman 89
Fifth Element and yeah I love seeing the
guy pop up in every movie that he does
either way him falling into the fan
covers up the fact his animorph is out
there but paranoia slowly seeps back
into Ripley's head over pillow talk with
Clemens she talks about having a
terrifying dream during hyper sleep and
this is some of the Kane's dream of
smothering in the first film strange
things start to happen with inmates
slowly disappearing and again not to hop
on too much about the different cuts but
look you know how much I was dreading
going back to this film however watching
the longer version wrap me up in its
mystery and I love seeing the prisoner
slowly start as a spec that something
was off Clemens ends up getting called
in by the warden and on his desk we can
catch a nodding blue bird two of these
appeared at the start of the first alien
film and really Scott put them in place
before shadow of the eggs we got down
the line Ripley ends up dragging Bishop
out of the trash and at this point she's
jump which leads to Dylan rescuing her
now I never really picked up on this but
now playing went through how
inconsistent his character was and
looking at it with his is many knowledge
I can kind of see the seams now Dylan is
someone who goes from thinking Ripley's
sin embodied and by just being a woman
he calls her intolerable in the next
scene though he's saving her life before
becoming her closest Ally in the wake of
clemens's death they pointed out that
he's actually a victim of the numerous
rewrites and script changes that the
movie had happened to it with him
basically being either friendly or
completely hating Ripley depending on
what version you read now his death was
also changed numerous times throughout
the production with him initially giving
his life in the Assembly Hall to stop
the xenomorph from killing Morse he was
also gonna discover a nested at build
with several bodies cocooned up against
the walls for the impending alien queen
if you go back and re-watch alien and
Aliens you might notice that the
Xenomorphs rarely tend to actually kill
people and most of the time they just
tend to drag them off alright this
xenomorph just murders people out right
whereas the Cocoon scene was meant to be
more consistent with the rest of the
franchise anyway Ripley ends up bringing
Bishop back online and these effects I
think still look incredible the crazy
thing is that the people who made the
cast for this didn't even have Lance
Henriksen for the mold and they did most
of this separately by building two
dummies the second was only made because
the first didn't seem to look enough
like Lance and Fincher actually wanted
to have even less of a head oh that they
didn't completely scrap it and this
first version was placed primarily in
all the white shots either way you
compare this to the ash head and alien
and you can see how much the industry
improved when it came to special effects
like this although this movie is really
Bleak they do kind of have a dark sense
of humor to it with Bishop jokingly
saying that his legs hurt and that he
likes Ripley's hair the warden also dies
during a scene in which he gives a big
speech about how the xenomorph doesn't
exist just before he's pulled up in an
event which leads to his little bouncy
ball dropping down hilariously watching
the guy mop up his entrails and worldly
looking up into the vents always cracks
me up and moments like this did start to
win me round when I was doing this
re-watch now what finchy did brilliantly
is that balance these moments out with
some Unforgettable horror unfortunately
though I think that the death of Clemens
coming out of nowhere and the way it
does initially made a lot of people
start a turn on this movie we went from
having someone we'd seen Ripley buddy up
to for the entire film who had been
given the majority of the character
development and pretty much the entire
Spotlight outside of her after his death
the warden gets killed quickly after and
thus well left with characters who've
had a little to no screen time which
kind of makes you stop caring about the
group as a whole now I also think that
the movie suffers from not having the
distinct Personalities in the crew that
the first two films had for example
every single side character in the team
in both alien and Aliens was standouts
at I think you could pick out of a
lineup here though you've got about 20
generic clean-shaven skin heads that all
dress the same and are roughly the same
age you don't really gravitate towards
him like you did those any other films
and the ones you get to know like
Clemens are killed at the midpoint so
watching him him being taken out just
feels like a massive gut punch however
it is impactful and it's also followed
up by one of the most iconic shots in
cinema history the xenomorph up next to
Ripley's Summit will burn itself into
your brain and I can imagine it's one of
the first things that come up if you
Google the movie you also probably get
the film's iconic poster too and we can
see from the head of the small chest
burster here that this is a queen which
is a nice little hint to what's inside
of Ripley Ripley lasts way longer than
the other people in the franchise who
just stated Xenomorphs instead of them
but this is primarily down ahead having
a queen which takes far longer to grow
anyway they launched their first attack
but the preparation for this is cut
short when the xenomorph attacks Midway
setting off a gigantic explosion we get
a great bit of foreshadowing when the
sprinklers put out the blaze on the
floor we see a cracked bucket which then
shifts on its own as the thermal
reactions caused this is how the aliens
kill later on with the heat from the
lava being contrasted by the thermal
shock of the sprinklers there this
reaction happens due to a rapid change
in temperature which shifts molecules
about quickly and causes materials to
crack heat makes something expand
whereas cold temperatures contract it
unless these two things happening at
once causes structural failure a Golic
at one point tells Ripley that she's
gonna die too correctly predicting her
fake come the end of the movie spoiler
alert
now I think the moment of the inmates
getting a victory here works way better
than the loss than they get in the
theatrical cut it's harrowing seeing
that one guy realize that he's gonna
have to leave this enema up in the
chamber in order to trap it and hearing
his screams from behind the door adds so
much more to the sacrifice he's just
given I think they needed a win here
whereas in the theatrical cut it just
feels like all the Death was for nothing
and they don't get the Breather that
allows them to learn what the company's
up to in the original version it doesn't
make much sense for them to be standing
around doing nothing whereas here Ripley
learns the company's dead set on getting
her in the xenomorph they deny
permission to destroy it and whilst this
is going on Golic freeze it once more to
make matters worse Ripley discovers the
embryo inside of her and after realizing
the xenomorphone kill it she goes on the
hunt traveling into the basement she
does this because she discovered the
hive was located in the lower levels
during the previous movie the company
also announces that they'll be there in
two hours and we get a shot of their
ship in space echoing the solocco with
its gun shape and structure now in the
basement we see the alien further using
the environment to its advantage in our
previous breakdowns we've talked about
how the ship designs were purposely done
to mirror the xenomorph and this allowed
it to camouflage itself into the
environment that's the case here with a
creature hiding amongst the pipes and
Ripley somewhat hallucinates seeing it
as they have the creature crouched down
this is revealed to just be a pipe but
rewind that mate because you can't fool
me that that is the suit now instead see
it located in the vents Above hair
blending in perfectly with the
environment it won't kill Ripley unless
she realizes that she needs to be used
as a weapon we get a big rousing speech
from Dylan and you might notice that
this large red Japanese letters painted
on the wall these appear throughout the
movie and they represent not only well
in yutani but they also translate to
mean Iron due to this being a Refinery
now this location provides the perfect
place for a final chase scene with the
humans attempting to leave the
xenomorphin in the mold a love the use
of this animal's point of view is it
races through the corals leading to a
really transaction scene as it whittles
down the survivors now as this is going
on we get the arrival of Lance Henriksen
now this guy being an Android and art is
somehow it's been debated back and forth
amongst the alien Community for decades
to make manners more confusing Lance
Henriksen said conflicting things
depending on what interview you read
sometimes he is and sometimes he isn't
and the credits themselves also list
them as playing the character Bishop too
and this has led a lot of people to
believing that he's an Android but there
are some clues that have actually
cleared up the confusion although the
credits have been said to have been a
mistake by the creative team the two is
true but not in the way we think in
Aliens versus Predator we see Lance
playing a character called Charles
Bishop who we learn founded the whaling
Corporation in Aliens colonial Marines
it's actually said that his name's
Michael Whalen so at some point it
probably changed the bishop therefore
Michael Bishop could have been an
ancestor and then the character we see
here is Michael Bishop the second rather
than being the second version of Bishop
now when the character is clocked at the
end we see his ear hanging off and
there's red blood dripping from it
though the ear is at an angle that I've
never seen a human have before it is
important to bear in mind that there's
red blood rather than the white Bluey
that we see dripping out of damaged
Androids there's also the script which
says Ripley looks up at him and we get
the description no wires no milk real
blood now in addition to this bishop
here actually shows genuine emotion to
Ripley and a pump being clocked over the
head it doesn't suffer from speech
changes in every other alien movie
whenever an Android's damaged like this
their voice becomes more digitized which
isn't the case here therefore I think
that this is a real man and the reason
is here goes like this is because he has
some cybernetic Parts located within his
head being higher up in the company
could mean that he has access to Tech
like this and can enhance himself to a
certain level anyway back with Dylan and
Ripley we see as the former remains
behind so you can keep the xenomorph in
the mold the boiling hot lead seemingly
kills it but the xenomorph shows just
how indestructible It Is by crawling its
way out in the end Ripley manages to
kill it but there's just one specimen
left now I can't remember this line in
the theatrical cut but Bishop offers her
this
you still can have a life
children
Ripley's entire Rock in the second movie
was based around motherhood with her
learning of her daughter's death before
she became a surrogate one to Newt
though Bishop says that he wants to take
the creature out of her to kill it this
isn't the case as when she goes to end
her life he reveals what he actually
wants to do
the Magnificent special he also calls a
creature a magnificent specimen which is
what Bishop did in the previous movie
now this would very much be a deal with
the devil in which she would get a
family and to be a mother again but it
would cost countless lives and
ultimately lead to more death thus uh
turning it down shows she's a true hero
and we also see this reflected in the
character Aaron though he was talking
about returning home to his wife and
child we watch as he dies after
attacking Bishop he's fired up by the
guards who are on with m41a pulse rifles
which other weapons that the Marines
used in the prior entry in the end this
leads to Morse being the sole survivor
and though Ripley assumed the company
would kill everyone he is Left Alive we
also know his fate from this point
onwards and Morse was transported to
another classy prison which is where he
was plagued with nightmares eventually
he lost his faith in religion and though
he was threatened by the company to not
discuss anything that happened on the
planet he did go against this he
published a book called space beast and
2183 which didn't sell many copies and
it was quickly banned however we do know
from the Alien Resurrection script that
Cole read a copy of it which allowed her
to learn about Ripley and also the
xenomorph anyway that closes out the
movie and we hear Ripley's final message
from the first film before we end
transmission
this is Ripley
last survivor open this drama
signing off
this is Ripley
last survivor of the Nostromo
signing off and that's alien 3. looking
back I'm glad you guys twisted my arm
into doing this as I actually enjoyed
the retread in the end though it's
definitely the worst out of the first
three I think there's a lot to like here
if you dig deep enough and seek out the
superior longer version this movie would
actually go on to majorly shaped benches
career and he moved away from doing
Studio driven films to work on his own
stuff which gave her more creative
control was a smart move too as we've
had a number of Classics from him over
the years David Troy also ended up
reworking his original vision and this
became you guessed it pitch black now we
also have this amazing audiobook of the
original plans for the movie out there
too and looking back you know it might
have worked out for the best all in all
I also think there's a lot to like from
this movie and I hope you enjoyed our
retread through it just as long as you
guys don't make me watch Alien
Resurrection we should be oh you're
gonna make me do it aren't you you're
gonna make me
[Music]
now I want to do rubber cop next and
then the first two Terminators and then
I'll probably return to Resurrection to
resurrect this series thank you for all
your support on it and it's been great
watching you guys love these other
breakdowns as much as I love doing them
if you want some else to watch then make
sure you check out our video on Aliens
which will be linked on screen right now
by the way a huge thank you for clicking
this I've been poor I'll see you next
time take care peace